James and I are going to carry on with ping
pong. Now I'm rubbish at ping pong. James
is much better than me. But this gets much
trickier when you take gravity away, so let's
have a look at that.
'Injection.' OK, game on. Now I had to have
quite a lot of ping pong balls for this because
I kept losing them, and you keep losing them
because you're floating. The balls are floating,
and they just don't do what they do do on
Earth. I'm not entirely sure--
[LAUGHTER]
I have no idea, OK?
So the ball doesn't behave like this. The
laws of physics are the same, but the physics
of your situation have changed, so everything
is more difficult. Alex, shall we have a quick
game? Yeah?
[LAUGHTER] All right.